it looks like Robo taxis need a serious
reboot a driverless car company curving
half of its Fleet in the Golden State
after a string of mishaps the California
DMV launching an investigation after a
robo taxi collided with a fire truck on
its way to an emergency the robocar
Apparently had a green light but
problems with the vehicle's ability to
chart the path of the fire truck led to
the crash later that same night a
different car collided with another
vehicle nearby but none of that will
stop San Francisco from rolling out a
plan to green light a driverless bus
service which runs daily on a fixed
route to test how autonomous vehicles
can improve public transportation all
right the truth Herald is that since
last year they've made over 600
unplanned stops on the public Streets of
San Francisco so why is the city now
approving a bus service this makes no
sense it's the um I think I love it when
people have big visions and big ideas
and do a lot of work to try to make it
to make it happen but at some point it
when it runs into reality and collides
with reality it collides with things and
it may you have to pause this like I
still have reservations about AI Dana's
made up for a persuasive argument to me
about how Triumph we if we pause too
much we could Advance China but this
here and you you may be right but this
here this this strikes me as this is the
The Innovation Hub of the country and
arguably the world the San Francisco
area and I would hope that they don't
allow hubris to get in the way of being
being smart and safe with how they treat
and how they transport people we've seen
the data that this somehow another could
be safer than having human beings Drive
well
uh the data right now says it's not safe
it's having human beings Drive I would
much rather ride on a bus with a human
driving even Jesse driving than I would
a uh way to throw your fellow AI under
the bus Heralds yeah you know Jesse
there are over 55 incidents of these
Robo taxis interfering with fire
department response some of the delays
in up to 30 minutes and you know so it's
kind of ironic that these vehicles that
are supposed to be safe are getting in
the way of safety you know what else is
ironic judge what someone at this table
I'm not going to name their names I'm
not into that whole kind of thing but
they think they know everything about
technology and they've made a lot of
predictions about how things would be
better if we just had robots Drive our
cars and I poo pooed it and then I was
you know mocked for doing so I myself
sat here at this table one year ago and
said these things are stupid and
dangerous and are going to get people
hurt and some other person won't say who
it is but they're a little arrogant not
Dana and also to my left said
this is the wave of the future and this
is perfect
I'm still not going to say the person's
name but it is ironic isn't it I think
you're using the word ironic incorrectly
yeah I'm only using it incorrectly
because she used it incorrectly oh there
you have it okay almost 70 of the people
uh Dana say that they're afraid of these
self-driving cars so why are they
pushing them well I think it's because
there's this quest for a green Utopia
that is basically has the country in a
hysteria as well at least part of the
country and certainly Joe Biden remember
he's under a little bit of pressure
because a couple of weeks ago when he
was pressed by the media he said in a
speech he said he had declared a climate
emergency oh it was the interview with
the Weather Channel you said I've
already declared a weather a climate
emergency she said you have you had like
well he hasn't but imagine what would
happen if he did when was the last time
the government caught said that there
was an emergency it was during covet and
what could they do they shut down
schools shut down businesses make you
wear a mask when you could do all of a
sudden so what could happen imagine what
could happen if they declared an actual
climate emergency but the government
could do and part of it is this and
there's this green Utopia that they have
in their mind that they're going to get
to maybe we will get there one day but
they're going too far too fast people
are going to get hurt I don't see why
you couldn't create a little area and
test these things out for a lot for a
long time until we figure out when if
they work well that's what they're doing
that's exactly what this is uh everybody
is scared of new technology people were
terrified of flying people were
terrified of cars and you know what's
interesting about automobiles driven by
humans we were okay with our relatives
and family members dying every year
between what 50 to 100 000 people dying
every year we didn't even Institute seat
belt mandatory seat belts until what
like the 70s we had people flying
through windshields we didn't give a
damn because we loved our cars but now
you have possibly the safest the safest
thing that could happen and we're all
going no do you know that there's not
there's been one fatality I think from
self-driving cars they have done
millions and millions and millions of
driving they're testing this out give it
give it 10 years we gave the automobile
industry 80 years we gave them a million
deaths you can handle a self-driving car
and you know what you know what's great
though Jesse you're gonna love it
because that's going to give you more
time to play with your hair system okay
I stand with taxi drivers you don't
stand with Uber oh you know what okay
stand with truck driver what about
horse-drawn carriages horse-drawn
carriages and with horses too and the
men whipping them from the buggy
up next who hasn't wanted to do this a
pilot sick of waiting on a long line
going ballistic on a parking lot arm hey
everyone I'm Emily compagno catch me and
my co-host Harris Faulkner and Kaylee
mcineny on outnumbered every weekday at
12 pm Eastern or sets your DVR also
don't forget to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page for daily highlights